[Music]
this slow motion undusting scene is so
very cool but again brings up so many
questions and since the sims channels
have already had a few swings at this
let's just focus instead on the story of
44 year old ronald j
tesh of republic missouri on the day of
the snap ronald was walking his farm
with his wife when he disintegrated
right in front of her eyes
a year later the still-grieving widow
had to sell the land to amazon for a
distribution center
and take a job there as a line
supervisor four years after that on the
day of the reverse snap she was doing
her daily checks just as her late
husband reappeared
standing in the midst of the mechanical
jungle his confused look didn't last
long as his upper torso was split by the
assembly belt now
occupying that space and his wife
watched his now bisected lifeless corp
slowly proceed through the now gruesome
assembly line so
great job avengers
this subtitle implies that monica rambo
is in fact maria rambo's daughter who is
a character from captain marvel but it's
hard to make out what the off-screen
voice is saying and if you don't have
the subtitles on you're more likely to
miss that captain marvel is the one
that's talking
if the reveal is supposed to be a
surprise down the road then a sin for
secret spoiling subtitles and if this is
supposed to be pertinent information
then a sin for needing the subtitles on
yes i know i'm complicated not watching
where you're blipping
doctor thank you where did you go
one of the brilliant things about the
connectedness of the mcu is the ripples
of reveals like this
now that we know monica got dusted when
you watch in-game the captain marvel
stuff becomes even more personal it's
honestly an incredible tool in their
belt and props to marvel for
understanding the power of complex canon
building
wait what this is a marvel property i'm
watching
it's bad enough i have to remember what
shield means which for the record
i do not now you're throwing sword at me
two too many acronyms marvel
i'm over acronymed also sentient weapon
observation response division may be the
dumbest acronym
ever a full division dedicated to the
response to observing sentient weapons
how many sentient weapons are we dealing
with here also also if i'm understanding
the people who would prefer i pronounce
jif giff then this should actually be
pronounced sward
since the o stands for observation good
to know
i'll make sure i do that from here on
out i work here if you did your badge
would work wouldn't it
i know there are apple leaders out there
working reception desks but considering
billions of people just reappeared on
the earth a couple weeks ago this kind
of response seems like it's more to set
up the
you know this is cliche rather than
anything approaching reality you have an
agent a day
it was five years not 50 unless she was
seven expecting someone to have aged
visibly in five years is just silly and
if it's just some lame attempt at blip
humor well i'm sending your delivery
getting stuck with the nickname photon
it also says observation
and response on that door not creation
the world's not the same as you left it
there is nothing more exciting in a
superhero series than a discussion about
corporate prioritization
the fbi isn't a tizzy over a missing
person's case
southern jersey missing persons i know
but they've requested use of one of our
imaging drones
but wouldn't a request like that require
more information suarez is an
organization that has to deal with
situations on a galactic level why would
they be interested in helping out the
fbi in this capacity with this little
knowledge going in
new jersey james ew fbi
did you see that he did the card trick
ant-man showed him man
i can't keep taking sins off for these
marvel links so here's a sin for
show taking three full episodes to
randall park and kat dennings i guess
pardon me sheriff would you mind
repeating your claim about west view to
my colleague here
no such place many mysteries from the
previous three episodes get solved over
the next half hour
still one puzzle not pieced together is
how the local law enforcement would be
under wanda spell but wu and rambo
aren't they're standing in front of the
same sign the police officers are also
how has
no one else driven into west view before
now maybe the town isn't on a major road
but it's still on a road that could be a
shortcut for someone looking to shave
off a few minutes of their commute
did all those people get a makeover in a
new identity these reveals are exciting
but they also make one wonder if wanda's
plan isn't terrible
i think wanda's plan might be terrible
why haven't you gone inside to
investigate
because it doesn't want me to oh
growing up other kids had michael jordan
posters on their walls but i had elliot
ness where would you even find an
elliott nest poster pre-internet and yes
i know the untouchables was a popular
movie in the late 80s but those would be
kevin costner
posters scene only contains one broke
girl also how many mcu movies do we have
to remember to keep the names and
connections of the sporting characters
straight
at least the avengers movie stuck mainly
with the big guns if you immediately
recall who darcy lewis or jimmy wu is i
salute you but i shouldn't need a cheat
sheet to understand your show
sward response base isn't response
already in the acronym why not just call
it the suare divisional base for
observation in response this is truly
some top-notch
terrible acronyming
those drones you're sending in what kind
of data are you getting
the beginning of this episode
annihilation's so hard that if cat
dennis doesn't eventually find some sort
of nightmare bear
roar screaming the word drone i'm gonna
be severely disappointed
also drones you guys look like you might
get down with those
little pod things horrendous for the
environment technically this is a true
statement but k-pods are also recyclable
so this is more about laziness than
environmental concern darcy
while the crew cut does seem like an
[ __ ] you didn't actually ask for
assistance
there's no reason to suspect the
perimeter doesn't extend subterraneously
jimmy would be fresh off the boat at tv
since so you're saying the universe
created a sitcom
starring two avengers show includes
confused fan ramblings frustrated at not
being able to binge the whole season of
juan division
have some patience you spoiled streamer
babies wait it's ending
i mean i know you wanted to wink back at
the mid-credit easter egg of the first
episode but when we first see the show
they're at the start of the boss visits
for dinner scene which was a good 10
minutes before the show's credits and
considering this entire real-time
conversation lasts less than three
minutes
i think you may have fudged on the show
timeline quite a bit there whiteboard
from the sins writing room desperately
trying to figure out how to sin a
mystery in real time is somehow
transported onto the show
wait a second have we even seen this i
don't think it's in the first two so
does this mean there might be another
episode of the bewitched or dick van
dyke style shows
are you holding out on sd plus release
the dick cut
what that's honestly not the worst way
that could have gone wanda
can you read me over this kind of works
but then in the episode she somehow
rewound out of this moment
so what happened to this guy when she
did that if real objects and people get
integrated into the time period fine but
i'm presenting that we will likely never
get an explanation
to the paradox of the timing of all this
and if we do then i'll be happy to take
a sin back
okay i'll begrudgingly take a sin back
okay fine i'll pretend to take us in
back and then make some snarky comment
and actually addison instead
happy now seriously a whole staff set up
to painstakingly watch episodes of
television to break them down looking
for meaning in minutia are we really
supposed to believe such a place would
exist
[Music]
oh he's perfect
twins but they shouldn't know that yet
in the previous episode rambo delivered
the one baby and then they discovered a
second one was coming after vision came
in with the doctor
but where's rambo not answering this
question was some variation of probably
in a headband off brutally killing some
people in a jungle somewhere in the name
of justice
and i want you
once again i have to ask how wanda's
powers work at times she can make
something appear with the snap of her
fingers
so why couldn't she simply make monica
disappear now wanda has more unnecessary
cleanup just snap your fingers you've
done it several times so far
why would wanda see this version of
vision this would mean he's dead
and he isn't dead he is perfectly fine
and everyone will be happy and how dare
they try to make any of us believe
otherwise
oh crash on my eye glass in my eye
secretly love movies shh have they had a
podcast devoted to discussing movies
called sim cast since 2015
have they had a vast array of movie
talks deep dives games guest interviews
q a and much more on the sim cast damn
it i said keep it down oh screw it the
secrets out check out the scene cast
every monday
and more wherever you do your podcast we
have fun
we have an agent today go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
what about you i've got a butthole and
it's working overtime
careful rambo they drew first blood not
me
wow i mean
whoa
are you i'm batman
what is it what's wrong i see dead
people
monica you okay we have to go back kate